Consciousness in the brain has always
been likened to the current information
processing technology going back to the
Greeks with a seal ring and wax for
memory and then Telegraph switching
circuits the Hologram and then uh the
computer of course in the last uh 50
years it's been the computer and AI has
come along and run with that idea and
say when we get complex enough or we get
enough this or that we'll have
Consciousness and I think that's
completely wrong because I follow Roger
idea that Consciousness is
non-computational and there's something
other than computation something other
than a touring machine going not